30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
I'm Joanna so and today's workout is
going to be a core and strength focus so
for every exercise we want to engage and
activate your core muscles okay so it is
going to be a total body workout what
you'll need is a pair of lightweight
damsels I would say between three to
four kilos each
let's start with a quick warm-up today
should have with a pad look at toys
pointed forward and slowly lower
yourself down into a squat position and
point your arms up
good so feel the stretch on your back
feel the work on your legs as well as
your glutes keep going remember to keep
your chest up
and look straight ahead nice easy and
gentle just wicking all the muscles up
make me two more one and last one - all
right very good
now take a step forward let's get into a
reverse lunge with a twist okay so step
your left leg back twist and now right
leg back and twist again still warming
up our body twist and step back each
step try to lunch lower okay bring your
knee close to the floor very good do you
more last one more on each side
step back and come back up all right now
take a step back and let's get into inch
one to a push-up and slowly inch back
come up inch forward push up give me
four all right and if possible keep both
legs straight if you need to you can
bend your knees slightly last one more
down push up back up and just raise your
hands up good okay grab your dumbbells
the first workout is going to be a
reverse lunge with shoulder press ok so
Dumbo's by your side step back press it
up forward back and press it up good so
this workout is going to engage your
core muscles okay find your balance
find a focal point
and at the same time we want to work on
your shoulders good back and step back
good keep it slow keep it steady back
into a lunge press it up feel the power
feel the strength from your shoulders
keep going woo and drop it down okay now
let's get down onto the mat into a plank
row with a knee tucks alright so again
using both dumbbells if you're
comfortable you can place your arms on
both of the dumbbells if not place one
palm on the floor so let's start with a
row on the left right tuck it in work
your inner core left right in and out if
for an easier version what you can do is
left place your palms down right in and
out left right in and out okay for the
advanced version grab hold of both
dumbbells good keep going
remember to stay in a plank position
do not Pike your butt up last one
and back done okay now let's lie down on
the mat still holding onto our dumbbells
let's get into a bridge position okay
place both dumbbells up facing each
other so let's start with a bridge fly
into reverse crunches give me two flies
up squeeze the glutes to and I bring it
down get into a reverse crunch back into
a bridge squeeze it squeeze it point it
down lower yourself reverse crunch and
up squeeze and squeeze so we want to
work on your lower abs at the same time
up and get your car find your balance
down push it up back down working on a
chest reverse fly and reverse crunch
good breech fly ok very good
ok now let's get back up put the
dumbbells aside still working on your
chest and your core muscles
spider-man push-up ok so let's get into
a high plank position ok start in a high
plank position as you go get into a
push-up lower yourself down and bring
your knee to your elbow okay so it's
spider-man push up as low as you can
bring your knee to your elbow very good
in and out again do not rush through the
workout nice and steady
keep going good bring it down lower
yourself into a push-up and work on your
obliques by driving your knee to your
elbow very nice
last few more keep going last one there
and take a short break now if you have a
lighter pair of dumbbells grab them ok
the next workout is going to work on
again another plank position with a
twist so choose your options either grab
both dumbbells or place one hand on the
floor so I want you to keep your arm
straight into a twist
type in your core and now on the other
side twist
up lower yourself down up and bring it
down
good find your balance activate your
core muscles good keep going in and
breathe out
whew the work on your shoulders your
arms and abs
that's one more all right
still holding on to the light dumbbells
let's lie down onto the floor this is
probably one of the hardest workout but
it's also my favorite Superman squeeze
so you can do this without any weights
lie down to the floor look straight down
okay and now let's move your body up and
squeeze your back muscles point it
forward squeeze and point it forward
whew I can feel the intensity on my
shoulders if this is too tough
well you can do is lower it down bring
it up squeeze expel it drop it
up and squeeze good extended squeeze
extend and squeeze a few more squeeze
and if this is just too challenging drop
it
continue the workout without any weights
okay so choose your option lift your
chest off the floor squeeze up geeks and
now get back up and now let's grab the
heavier dumbbells okay get up and this
is your final workout for this second so
Stan why did I should have with a pot
stand in a sumo squat position place
both dumbbells in the middle the final
workout is going to be a Y SCAP jump
take your time okay
so lower yourself jump up bring both
legs together up find a balance and get
your car up do not rush this workout
really feel your entire body working Oh
balance good up into a wide
physician back down both dumbbells in
between your legs come up this is a
really good call workout Oh find that
balance
good down up good also working on your
upper body last one more down up very
good all right that was at the end of
the first circuit keep yourself hydrated
take a one minute rest okay right just
take this time to really breathe in
breathe out bring your heart rate back
down and we have two more seconds okay
so each second is only seven minutes
long and I want you to really push
through the circuit and give me your
best effort all right if you want to get
into a child's pose relax stretch it out
we have about 20 seconds of rest time
and it's back to the first workout okay
now let's get ready okay choose your
option go for slightly heavier I would
say between four to five kilos each and
now let's start at the front of your mat
the first workout is going to be a
reverse lunge with sure the press okay
so press it up bring it in as you drive
your leg back push the dumbbells
straight up good
reverse lunge with a shoulder press
tighten your core engage your car suck
your belly in drive your knee close to
the floor and push up good push it up
and down up and down
whew
oh I love this workout it challenges my
balance as well push it up down keep
going and now let's get down into a
plank position
plank row so either place your pumps
onto the mat or grab both dumbbells okay
so let's get into a high plank
all right let's go left um up row right
and one knee tucks out back into a plank
so do not Pike your butt up row squeeze
your back muscles and now working on
your core squeeze it bring the dumbbell
close to your belly
row it row left and right very good
see that drip on the mat but it's my
sweat
what loving the effort okay now let's
lie down on your back and let's get into
a breech position
so both dumbbells up breech position
remember to squeeze your glutes through
other workouts and we want to start with
a fly okay so up two flights and one
reverse crunch one tap to bring it down
push it up back into a bridge up one two
again down working on your lower abs up
squeeze the chest so do not rest your
hands on the floor it's just a gentle
tap up good keep going down push it up
and back down squeeze the chest muscles
feel your chest working push it up and
remember to keep your elbows slightly
bent
and good job all right back up place the
dumbbells down Oh still working on our
plank
spider-man push-up okay so start in a
high plank position
good let's go in a high plank position
and as you get down into a push-up drive
from knee to your elbow feel the squeeze
on the obliques good keep going and if
this is too tough what you can do is
drop down on your knees slide and slide
okay so you can still do the workout
even if you're on your knees choose your
option I see your progress come back up
push it and lower yourself down Lois
I've done very good
hah this is a total body strength and
conditioning workout last few more one
more
and done okay grab the light dumbbells
rotational plank all right again if you
feel that you don't have enough strength
on your wrists you can always place your
pumps on the floor okay okay so let's
start high plank twists arm straight
look straight up twist and look at your
palms twist very good balance yourself
if you feel that you are shaking that is
absolutely fine that's your muscles
working twist
remember do not dip your butt down so
stay in a high plank position
and keep going up and down
up and down that's one more up down and
now you just place the weights in front
of you get down onto your belly take a
short break
Superman squeeze oh my god
we are not stopping now all right this
workout is not easy at all even if you
only have one killer that is absolutely
fine so up squeeze remember chest off
the floor squeeze the glutes games
gently on the floor squeeze the back
muscles hold it for two counts extend
feel the work on your shoulders and
squeeze extend and squeeze good if at
all you need to stop take a shot break
and get straight back into the workout
squeeze very good last ten seconds ahh
a few more give me one more extend
squeeze and just drop the weights okay
no get back okay grab your dumbbells
whoo okay step white in a sumo squat
position oh my god feels like I just got
out of the shower please both dump us in
the middle of your legs get into a squat
position jump up into a white position
back down swing the dumbbells back down
use the strength of your core to swing
the dumbbells up up swing it up types in
your car find your balance right at the
top before you jump back into a sumo
squat up good halfway there up down up
back down up very good
last ten more seconds keep going give me
at least two more one more up that was
the end of your second second you are
not done this is a solid 30 minutes
workout take a one-minute break and it's
on to your final seven minutes all right
take a one-minute break if you feel that
you want to stretch it out a little bit
you can do that get into a plank and
into downward dog okay
feel the stretch and the cops your back
muscles back into a plank and stretch it
out I want you to slow your breathing
down and bring your heart rate back down
into a plank and push it back into
downward facing dog very good and not
just drop your knees and get into a
child's pose 15 seconds left
alright and now slowly get back up let's
get ready for our final circuit okay are
you ready for this it's going to be fun
both dumbbells by your side right stand
it shoulder width apart
tighten your core and now let's go press
it back bring it down back and down good
step as far back as you can into a lunge
back and down good remember you're
pressing straight up the dumbbells
should be right above your head it
should not be moving forward or moving
back
keep going breathe in and breathe out
breathe in out and in few more you are
strong
good and now let's get down into a plank
position
plank row with knee tucks alright okay
let's start in a high plank hold this
position for another five seconds and it
straight into plank row so type in a car
do not pipe okay let's go left right
knee tucks left and right remember you
want your elbows to be pointing back so
do not spread it out to the side in and
out point it back back and try not to
sway your hips too much left and right
keeping your hips facing towards the
ground left and right and in and out
good so do not do this okay this is
wrong knee tucks and one more very good
okay you know the next workout straight
down it's going to be a bridge pose with
a chest fly and a reverse crunch okay so
hold this position hold this position
for another five seconds I want to
engage your glutes and get your [ __ ]
core and now let's go squeeze it one two
bring it down push it up up back down
tap gently on the floor bring it back
down push it up good straight back down
into a high bridge pose back down push
it up up good squeezing your glutes
engaging your glutes at the same time
back down do the work on your lower abs
crunch crunch good down push it up up
very good one more give me one more and
good now drop the weights place the
dumbbells down your favorite push-ups
okay so choose your option either on
your knees or on your toes all right
with a spider mint on crunch let's go
crunch it crunch it lower yourself down
down and down good just like a
spider-man imagine you're climbing up a
high building crunch and feel your left
oblique and your right side good keep
going down into a push-up down and up
very good ten more seconds left
oh push through this final circuit keep
going that's one long and up okay
rotational plank right let's challenge
yourself let's go for the heavier
dumbbell that doesn't mean you have to
rush through the workout okay so it's
all about challenging your core strength
so let's get into a high plank find your
balance slowly rotate lift it up and
bring it back down can you feel that it
is a lot more challenging for you to
balance yourself here and that way
you're good to engage your core
even more bring it back down if this is
too tough place your pumps on the floor
bring it back down pump on the floor
grab it
rotate back down or grab both dumbbells
good working on the strength of your
wrists as well back down few more give
me one more on each side
up down
final one up and done okay
no let's use a really light pair of
dumbbells lie straight down into a
Superman position okay stretch your body
out lengthen your legs toes pointed up
grab a dumbbell squeeze it extend it out
squeeze and at Stan so engage again
engaging your glutes and your legs as
well look straight down squeeze
good squeeze holy for two counts release
and squeeze oh I can really feel my
heart pumping ah I am burning calories
and so are you
keep going squeeze release and squeeze
my shoulders are absolutely burning whoa
squeeze it
last one more squeeze and just drop the
thumb down okay push yourself back up
all right ha oh look at this
sweat if you're sweating like me leave
your comments below okay alright grab
the heavy dumbbell start in a sumo squat
let's go up into a Y position white use
the chorus swing it up stand tall and be
proud very good up and stand tall
remember keeping your back straight
chest up
stand tall squat it down for your licks
working get low and get high go keep
going last 10 seconds up few more give
me three more okay guys see you more
that's one more all right come on one
lover good luck um and just drop the
weights down okay oh very very well done
you have completed three seconds of core
and strength focus no just get down onto
your knees I just want you to bring a
heart rate down my heart rate is going
crazy at the moment it's at 165 all
right just get into all fours and just
arch your back
let's stretch it out a little bit and
then curl it basically a cat and cow
position again look up release all the
tension on your back and again look down
and up
very good now let's get down and I want
you to slowly push yourself up into a
cobra position again do not sink into
your shoulders okay push your way from
your shoulders and really feel the
stretch on your back as well as your
shoulders and now slowly just get into a
child's pose
and just stay here for it is you're not
rushing to go anywhere you've completed
a good solid workout and just give your
body the time to relax and stretch
view your breath slowly lower your
breath and now just come back up get
into a standing position I just want you
to take three deep breaths okay so reach
up
get down breathe in and just release and
spy all out again breathing really long
ha ha
and last one more breathe in feel the
stretch and let's go loud really really
really well done I am sweaty I'm feeling
really good and I know that you did an
amazing job
so give yourself a high five if you
enjoy this workout then be sure to check
out my other strength training workouts
on my youtube channel I promise you if
you complete every single workout you
will be sweating you'll be feeling
really good you will improve on your
strength and you will see results so
check them out on my youtube channel and
don't forget to also subscribe I mean
what are you doing subscribe now and I
will see you in my next workout session
all the best